[Music]
welcome back everyone so we've been
talking about compressed sensing and
sparsity in general and now I want to
illustrate some of these concepts in
code in MATLAB okay so in particular
we've been talking about solving
underdetermined systems of equations of
the form y equals theta times some
sparse vector s ok so s might be a
vector of Fourier coefficients for an
image or an audio signal Y might be my
limited measurements I take of that
system so oftentimes this will be some
matrix C times some basis sy times s so
theta is kind of this measurement matrix
that tells me how I'm sampling my high
dimensional system ok so remember X
would be my original high dimensional
image may be a megapixel image is x in
pixel space s would be the Fourier
coefficients so that's a sparse vector
same dimension as X but in the Fourier
transform domain and C would probably be
some random matrix or some sparse random
matrix that would pull individual that
would sample individual pixels of X for
a much much lower dimensional
measurement Y ok and the whole game of
compressed sensing is out of all of
these infinitely many possible solutions
to s that could satisfy this
underdetermined system of equations and
when I say underdetermined I mean Y is
relatively small and s is relatively
large so there are many many more and an
S is the unknown variable so there are
many more degrees of freedom in this
unknown that I could I could kind of
fiddle with these these entries of s to
get the output Y this measurement Y and
there's lots and lots of different s
vectors that would give me the exact
same small output measurement that's
what I mean by an underdetermined system
of equations ok and so we're gonna do is
we're gonna code this up in MATLAB in
particular we're going to say that our
sparse vector has dimension 1,000 and
our output measurement Y is going to
have dimension 200 so this is going to
be one-fifth of the full measurements in
s theta is just going to be a
Oshin random matrix so rand and means
it's normally distributed random numbers
in a matrix of size P by n okay so I'm
kind of abstracting away this C times I
and I'm assuming theta is just a really
nicely behaved random matrix and then
for y I'm gonna say that Y is is just
some random vector okay so I'm just
creating theta to be a random matrix Y
as a random vector and we're gonna see
what happens when we try to solve for s
using different norms in our regression
okay so the easiest thing to do would be
least squares okay so we could do least
squares and this would this would again
be solved using the SVD which is from
chapter 1 of our book and so in least
squares you would say S equals theta
we're gonna call this theta dagger times
y where theta dagger is the pseudo
inverse you would take the SVD of theta
and then you'd invert each matrix one by
one those are unitary and diagonal
matrices so they're easy to invert and
this would give you the pseudo inverse
this is the least square solution or the
solution s that has the minimum norm in
an l2 sense okay so this is a kind of
minimum l2 norm and the alternative what
we're going to talk about so I'm going
to show you this least square solution
and we expect that s is not going to be
sparse at all it's going to have a
little bit of all of its entries filled
in and all of those entries are going to
work together to see might
simultaneously satisfy this equation and
make sure that s has the minimum l
2-norm possible okay and so generally
speaking having a lot of little entries
in s makes is better for the l2 norm
than having a couple of really really
big entries in s okay so that's what
this does the other one is the minimum
l1 norm solution which is essentially
kind of min the one norm of s such that
s I said such that y equals theta s is
true okay and there's a lot of ways to
write this I'm picking one way we'll see
how I actually write it in in the code I
think this is how I write it okay good
so we've created the data Y and theta so
those are known variables and we're
solving for s and we're gonna solve for
s these two different ways we're gonna
solve for s in the minimum l1 norm using
this is kind of the sparse solution so
this is really important because the
minimum one norm is gonna be a sparse
solution and we're also going to show
what the minimum l2 norm the
pseudo-inverse solution looks like for
comparison okay
okay good so to solve for the l1 minimum
norm solution and I'm just gonna call
this s underscore l l1 we're gonna use
the CVX package so you can go and
download this for free and this
basically is the convex optimization
package really really really powerful
makes makes optimization kind of general
optimization problems really easy to
code and solve in MATLAB so I highly
encourage you to download this CVX
package and what we're gonna do there's
this this this language kind of we're
gonna have the CVX begin CVX and that
means that we're gonna run this edx
optimization we're gonna optimize over
the variable s l1 and we have to tell it
explicitly what the dimension of this is
so it's dimension n where n was a
thousand and now we tell it that we're
going to minimize the one norm of s okay
so norm s comma one means the one norm
so we're going to minimize the one norm
of s subject to theta times s equals y
subject to y equals theta times s okay
so it's actually exactly how I wrote it
here is what we're doing here we're
going to minimize over the variable s
we're going to minimize that's one norm
such that it exactly equals or satisfies
this equation okay now if I added noise
to this if I had if this measurement Y
was theta s plus some noise so that this
couldn't be exactly satisfied I would
say subject to norm maybe I'll write
that out
subject to the norm of Y minus theta s
comma two that the two norm of Y minus
theta s less than maybe 0.001 I'd pick
some threshold and I would say that I
want to minimize the one norm of s
subject to the fit being within you know
ten to the minus three of the data okay
and this this threshold here would
depend on how large you think that
noises but we're not going to actually
worry about that right now we're going
to work in this perfect case where there
is no noise and this can be exactly
satisfied by by a vector s okay good so
we've solved that I'm actually going to
start this running because this might
take a little while okay good so I'm
running my l1 norm and then my l 2-norm
solution my minimum l 2-norm solution is
easy I just run the one-line MATLAB P in
of theta that computes the pseudo
inverse times y just I showed you okay
good so my CVX optimization is done you
can see that there's a bunch of outputs
here telling you kind of how this is an
iterative optimization to find the
sparse l1 minimizing solution and so
this is going through the item the the
iterative optimization until some
convergence criterion is satisfied it
tells you how many iterations and kind
of all of this information that you can
dig into if you really wanted to debug
your optimization but right now I really
just want to plot things for you and
show you what it's doing so here I am
going to basically plot everything all
at once okay and I'm gonna walk you
through it so we have these four plots
here on the Left panel in blue we have
the l1 solution I'm gonna tell you what
these what these mean and on the right
we have the l2 solution okay and what
you see here on this kind of top part of
the plot these the blue and the red top
plots each have a thousand elements this
is literally the vector s plotted value
by value okay so these are all of the
values of the S vector in the l1 minimum
norm solution and in the l2 minimum norm
solution and you
can see that the l1 solution is pretty
spikey okay so there's actually I don't
know if you can see but if you zoom in
here maybe I'll try to zoom in you can
actually see that if you zoom in a lot
of these values most of these values
actually are zero or very very small and
then there's occasional like large spiky
values so this is what we mean by our
solution being sparse many many many
many of the values are zero and a lot of
them are spiky okay and you see that
here this is our histogram of how many
of the values of s are zero or 0.1 or
0.02 or 0.03 oh four oh five and a
negative and so on and so forth okay so
most of the values are zero in fact you
can see almost about 800 of the values
are zero which makes sense because there
were only 200 values in Y and so I can
satisfy this equation with only 200
nonzero entries of s so about 800 of
them are in fact zero and then the
remaining 200 nonzero coefficients are
distributed out here in contrast the
least square solution the l2 solution
these are almost all nonzero all of the
values are nonzero and they're much
smaller okay so the l1 solutions
although most of them are 0 the
magnitudes are much larger whereas the
l2 solution has almost all of them
nonzero but they're much smaller in
magnitude so in the sum squared norm
this would have a smaller l2 norm this
would have a smaller l1 norm and again
if I look at the distribution the
histogram of these values what you see
now is that almost you know very few of
them are 0 this is not a sparse vector
many of them most of them are not 0 most
of them are kind of in this Gaussian
distributed bulk of values here ok so I
think that's a really nice illustrative
example of kind of what we mean by a
sparse vector and what these two
different norms do when you're solving a
basic underdetermined system of
equations ok so this was an under
under-determined
system of equations there were only 200
kind of measurements but a thousand
unknowns and when we solve for the l1
minimum solution for s we find that we
get a very very sparse solution where
800 of the values are nearly zero and
only 200 of those values are nonzero
required to satisfy this equation when
we said it when we solved the L to least
squares minimum solution we find that
this vector is not sparse at all the
solution vector has almost nonzero
entries and all of its entries but it
does have a smaller l2 norm
okay so this just goes to show that you
know it really matters what norm you
pick in an underdetermined problem like
this for solving for s so if you want a
sparse vector s you really really want
to penalize the one norm of s and you
can do that okay you can do that in
MATLAB using CVX all right thank you